[Musique]
bonsoir je débarque de somalie et du
coup j'imagine la première question sais
d'où je viens et où j'habite
merci compliqué spontanément j'ai
toujours envie de dire de pareilles la
ville de coeur là d'où je viens je suis
française d'origine éthiopienne
mais j'évite également en somalie à
mogadiscio vous situer un peu quand de
l'afrique paye assez dangereux vous
voyez devrait voir défiler des photos
assez rapidement donc comment est-ce
qu'on se retrouve à vivre en somalie
notamment dans une zone de guerre dans
une zone de conflit comment est-ce qu'on
choisit de partir de france pour ça va
tout simplement pour une question de
travail humanitaire et donc comment on
vit là bas qu'est ce que ça veut dire
donc la somalie c'est vivre dans un
espace qui est très militarisée très
armés c'est se déplacer en véhicule
blindé vivre dans un espèce de bon coeur
et porter des gilets pare-balles très
très lourd le plus souvent mais c'est
également quelque chose qu'on fait par
choix et donc car ce fut par hasard donc
j'étais comme vous étudiante en master
un peu hésitante entre ben un petit
voyage en inde un petit road trip avec
une copine pendant l'été ou être un peu
plus sérieuse et décidé d'aller au tchad
et c'est comme ça que pour la première
fois je me suis retrouvé en afrique
sub-saharienne dans le désert à 22 ans
et là ce fut un choc un choc tout
d'abord de culture de découverte un pays
si différents
si démunis mais également en conflit et
la découverte d'une d'une passion
l'humanitaire et concrètement vraiment
le choc d'une perception et d'une
réalité et gt j'imagine que beaucoup
d'entre vous ont aussi une perception de
ce qu'est l'humanitaire et qu'est ce que
c'est que l'humanitaire et bien c'est
très différent de ce qu'on imagine voilà
aujourd'hui j'ai 33 ans ça fait à peu
près dix ans que je fais ce travail et
on me demande encore tu volontaire donc
non je ne suis pas volontaire j'ai une
carrière rémunérés c'est un métier et le
reste du temps me demande si je suis
infirmière tout le temps c'est très
français
le l'humanitaire égale le médical
en revanche on ne m'a toujours pas
demandé si j'étais médecin bon coeur bon
à savoir pourquoi donc les militaires et
qu'est ce que ça veut dire à quoi ça
correspond
et bien tout d'abord c'est un mélange un
mélange de cultures de deux expertises
donc il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
généralistes dans ce milieu qui est très
professionnel et qui est très mouvant
qui s'adapte et beaucoup de généralistes
donc des gens comme moi comme vous des
passionnés de géopolitique de relations
internationales qui admire le monde va
tailler échanger des idées mais
également des experts des ingénieurs des
agronomes des psychologues des médecins
des personnes l'été avec des carrières
très très personnalisé très
professionnaliser comme certains des
experts convient de voir tout ce mélange
est également un mélange culturel
moi-même française d'origine piemme je
travaille à l'unicef dans mon bureau
actuel avec plus de 20 nationalités
différentes
donc vous imaginez on parle tous en
anglais pas forcément notre première
langue des coutumes des traditions des
façons d'approcher l'autre qui sont très
différentes et d'humanitaire c'est
également des choix de carrière
on peut travailler en ong ce que j'ai
fait pendant plusieurs années être
nations unies travaillent et donc à
l'unicef dans l'enfance
mais si on maintient de la paix est dans
des domaines plus politique ou auprès de
ministères où on apporte des expertises
et concrètement comme vous pouvez le
voir dans certaines des images derrière
ça passe aussi par des projets très
concrets
donc dans le cas de la somalie où on est
dans un contexte d' alerte à la famine
c'est essentiellement répondre à des
déplacements en masse de population
deux millions de personnes déplacées des
crises des épidémies de choléra mettre
en place des centres de traitement
rapide répondre à la malnutrition
comment cela se fait pas des fois c'est
aussi simple que d'affréter des gros
pick up et d'avoir des médecins des
infirmières et des médicaments qui vont
dans les différents villages et du coup
pourquoi pourquoi ce choix de
l'humanitaire et pourquoi choisir de
vivre dans des conditions qui ne sont
pas toujours les plus idéal donc pour ça
je propose qu'on revienne à un exemple
un peu plus contemporain en 2017 on a
beaucoup parlé de ce qu'on appelle les
famines notamment les noms
essentiellement dans le domaine
humanitaire et diplomatique
quatre pays de famine
le nigeria avec la crise de boko haram
le yémen avec le conflit en cours et la
crise du choléra
le soudan du sud où j'ai eu la chance de
vivre pendant deux ans et où un conflit
dure malheureusement depuis plus de
quatre ans et la somalie à la fois
sécheresse conflit qui continue des
déplacements en grand nombre et si je
vous dis famine
à quoi est ce que vous pensez je suis
sûr à 100% que la première réponse sera
la fin et la deuxième la sécheresse et
la famine avant tout c'est ce qu'on
appelle des mad mike reiss
ces crises qui sont faites par l'homme
qui sont la conséquence directe de nos
actions ces quatre pays ont en commun
d'être des zones de guerre et des zones
de conflit et du coup double la question
de l'engagement humanitaire laisse pas
merveilleux de se dire que par une
simple petite action quotidienne
on peut apporter une petite solutions à
des crises que nous contribuons à créer
au quotidien et il ya différentes formes
d'engagement
là vraiment l'idée n'est pas du tout
dedans la morale et de donner de leçons
être humanitaire n'est pas le meilleur
métier au monde n'est pas le messie le
plus noble mais c'est une option il ya
différentes façons de le faire et
aujourd'hui on est dans un monde où il
ya les étudiants votre génération se
pose énormément de questions et
notamment des questions de sens
comment donner un sens à son parcours à
son travail et à son quotidien et pour
ce faire il ya autant de formes
d'engagement humanitaire que d'individus
et du coup là est la question
comment s'engager comment le faire je
suis ici devant vous très épanouie très
heureuse fatigué l'évidence après dix
ans de crise humanitaire mais passionné
par cette réponse et du coup je vous
rends las la question quel choix
d'engagement humanitaire allez vous
faire merci
[Applaudissements]